nous ne le savons pas
mais nous sommes tous prisonniers de ces
étranges boucle temporelle
des milliards de gens qui mènent leur
petite vie anonyme
sans même y penser
l'heure est enfin venue
tu vas devoir nous montrer ce qui est
réel
[Musique]
oui je me souviens de ça
que tu déjà vu
et pourtant tout à l'air force
c'est peut-être pas l'histoire à
laquelle on pensait
il tord et éthique et
ils t'ont fait croire que leur monde et
est le seul digne de toi mais une part
de toi ça vexe et arrange
une part de toit se rappeler ce qui
était réel
et ses faces et et d'oublier le bruit
incessant que la matrice imprime dans
nos têtes
seul autre chose fait le même genre de
bruit
et la guerre
que votre venir néant
les plus importantes décisions de tours
il n'appartient pas
elle avait foire mois
tourre d'avoir x men
j'ai sûrement passer ma vie entière à
vous attendre
me revoir critique
parfois pour être
à
et les filles
j'ai vu tout ça dans mon rêve
ouais
[Musique]
je connais encore le conjoint